[Music]
if that's a thank you for having this
evening happen you're welcome
distinguished guests members of the
Society of environmental journalists my
friends and colleagues and our
colleagues from around the world members
of the International Federation of
environmental journalists joining our
activity here and of course members and
Friends of the MIT community and I'm
pleased to count some of them among my
friends I'm honored really thrilled it's
an exciting moment to welcome you all on
behalf of the Society of environmental
journalists we're here at MIT this
weekend conducting our fifth annual
conference as the Vice President will
learn as he's here and has a little bit
already in our conversation over the
course of the past few days we
journalists have discussed how it's
difficult time to be an environmental
journalist these days a true revolution
in fact is really underway in this
country and how our government handles
environmental protection and regulation
but even as that revolution is taking
place many believe in the news industry
that the news media are reducing our
attention to those issues just as the
public needs more information we seem to
be giving them less without information
of course people are not empowered to
act be there action in support of that
revolution or in opposition that's a
political question and not ours we don't
care it's not our role to prompt them to
act it is our role is as journalists
regardless of what we cover to inform so
that people will know what they need to
know to act as they choose and it is
specifically the purpose of the Society
of environmental journalists to enhance
the quality quantity and visibility and
accuracy of environmental journalism so
that people know what they need to know
about environmental issues and empowered
by that information can act on those
issues as they see fit that's what our
organization about that's what our
conference is about that's what this
evening is about and we are thrilled
that Vice President Gore has come
tonight because by his appearance here
he helps us and empowers us to do that
informing simply by his presence here at
izes the importance of environmental
journalism and for that we're grateful
before I introduce MIT president Charles
vest who will introduce the vice
president
let me explain briefly the outline for
the evening vice president will offer
his thoughts for a while and then take
our questions the questioning will be
limited to members of the Society of
environmental journalists members of the
International Federation of
environmental journalists and a
pre-selected member of the undergraduate
and graduate student bodies of MIT those
wishing to ask a question are asked to
come to the microphones there are four
in the aisles I'm sure you've spotted
them already please do wait until the
vice president has finished his remarks
and is taking questions there'd be a
tendency otherwise to rush the mics now
please identify yourself as you ask your
question and you are asked to remember
that lots of people will want to ask
lots of questions and there's only so
much time so be brief with that it's a
privilege to introduce MIT president
Charles vest and if I may before he
comes out or you can come out now if you
like president vest I would like to take
a word to note the fact that his
commitment to our conference here is one
measure of his recognition of the
importance of environmental issues and
science and research may I say on behalf
of the society in this company president
vest that we've had a rewarding
conference here no small measure due to
the intellectual richness of our host
thank you
[Music]
thank you David and good evening I'm
extremely pleased that Vice President Al
Gore has come to participate in your
conference and to answer some of the
many questions that are on your minds
regarding environmental issues we at MIT
are particularly happy to have the vice
president here this evening because we
feel a very strong affinity with his
environmental commitment over many years
of public service he is a man who
clearly understands that many actions
including those with scientific
technological and entrepreneurial
dimensions will be required to build a
clean and sustainable future you know of
course about his work to bring
environmental problems and opportunities
to the urgent attention of the public
but he's been working on many other
fronts as well one of these is
developing the national commitment to
science and technology that will be
needed to create jobs and to build the
economy as our industries and
institutions enter the 21st century his
efforts to shape and call attention to
the information infrastructure have been
tireless he has displayed a lively
appreciation for the role that research
universities including this one play in
educating problem solvers and in
developing a rational basis for
environmental action I've had the
pleasure of working with Vice President
Gore through my service on PCAST
the President's Committee of Advisors on
science and technology and I can tell
you firsthand that he is committed to
strengthening the synergy among industry
academia and government that is
necessary to develop effective
strategies to meet the critical problems
of our age he also has a great sense of
humor and an amazing breadth of
intellectual interests I'm quite
confident that Vice President Gore is
the only politician on the face of the
earth who can recite Tom Q's a structure
of scientific revolutions by art ladies
and gentlemen the vice president of the
United States
the Honorable Al Gore
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
and dr. Chuck vas thank you for your
very kind words thank you for your
participation in the PCAST Committee
advising the President on science and
technology and for your leadership in
science and education generally I'd like
to thank David ro Peak the conference
chair for his outstanding reporting on
the environment and his leadership of
this conference also to Amelia Ascari
the president of this society my sincere
congratulations to her and all who have
helped her make this meeting such a
success I'd like to thank Provost Joel
Moses for the hospitality and through
him and Chuck best all of the people at
MIT who have made us all so welcome here
and so comfortable here I want to
acknowledge State Representative Paul
DeMarcus and other distinguished guests
who are present there are some
distinguished guests who who aren't here
but because I'm talking about the
environment I want to acknowledge
Senator John Kerry my longtime ally on
environmental issues and of course his
wife Teresa has been an ally of mine on
environmental issues as well and we've
had many successful battles together as
I have with Ted Kennedy of course who
has been a champion of environmental
protection for many years and is a an
extremely capable advocate I'm really
glad to be here and you know MIT is one
of the places I can go to make a public
speech where people might think I'm
exciting
[Laughter]
the last time I was on campus briefly
was almost a year ago and I was still on
crutches and I I had had a basketball
injury I'm now out of the cast although
the doctors tell me I'll have to wear
the old full-body cast for several more
years it's okay I got used to those
jokes when I first ran for national
office it's no secret I ran for
president in 1988 although it seemed
like one at the time
I learned a lot of new jokes how can you
tell al gore from a room full of Secret
Service agents he's the stiff one if you
use a strobe light it looks like Al Gore
is moving Al Gore is so boring his
Secret Service code name is Al Gore I've
heard most of them by now every time I
hear a new and I always have the same
reaction
very funny tipper it was in order to
escape that demeaning ridicule and
reclaim my dignity that I decided to run
for vice president of the United States
of America I've enjoyed the experience
as a matter of fact not too long ago I
went on the David Letterman Show and I
was asked to give a list of the top 10
best things about being vice president I
won't go through the whole list but I
remember number 5 on the list which has
to do with the Great Seal of the vice
president if you close your left eye and
turn your head just right it says
president of the United States of
America
well it really is a great pleasure to
speak with this group because many
members of this group have shared some
experiences that I have in common with
you seeing a development that is
extremely important because it has a
huge impact on the air we breathe or the
water we drink or the earth that we hope
will be in as good shape for our
grandchildren as for us and yet when I
have tried to communicate the importance
of that particular story or event
sometimes encountered an audience that
doesn't see the environment the same way
I do
or doesn't feel its importance in
exactly the same way I do I dare say
that many of you have had that
experience when you have gone to manage
managing editors or city editors or the
news editors in the television newsroom
but slowly you are getting your point
across that regardless of your political
point of view or ideological posture
news about the environment is extremely
important to the American people they
want more of it they want better
analysis they want more information they
want more reporting two hundred and
twenty-two years ago in 1773 there was a
protest in this city that would become
one of the defining moments of America's
fight for independence I'm talking about
the Boston Tea Party
when Sam Adams and other members of the
Sons of Liberty disguised themselves and
threw boxes and boxes of tea off a
British trading ship now I'm not telling
you about this because it's a story of
careless dumping into Boston Harbor that
would come 200 years later and
incidentally the cleanup that followed
is one of our nation's great unfolding
success stories of safeguarding public
health and protecting our environment
and and let me pause to take this
opportunity to commend this city for the
wonderful job that has been done and
continues to be done in 1984 harmful
metals were entering the harbor at a
rate of three thousand pounds per day
and in 1993 that level was down to five
hundred pounds per day the number of
Boston Harbor Beach closings has been
reduced by 70 percent over the past four
years what changed well people both from
the private and public sector decided
that it was time for them to work
together and turn Boston Harbor from one
of the dirtiest harbors in America into
a healthy and clean environment that
could once again be a source of
recreation and a source of pride for
this city and state I could say more
about this unfolding success story but
let me get back to that Boston Tea Party
because back then the issue was taxation
without representation today what we're
seeing in Washington in the Republican
Congress is devastation with
misrepresentation devastation first
because the budget being put forward by
the Republican leadership would reverse
25 years of bipartisan progress it would
dismantle virtually everything we do to
protect public health and the
environment this Congress is the most
anti-environment Congress in the entire
history of the United States of America
and its agenda on the environment is an
extremist agenda it is a radical and
reckless agenda it is a harmful agenda
and it is an agenda that is completely
out of tune with the desires and wishes
and opinions of the American people
misrepresentation along with devastation
because time and time again the American
people have spoken out and said plainly
we Americans support the protection of
the environment we Americans Democrats
Republicans and independents liberals
moderates and conservatives we Americans
support protecting the environment but
when that message is delivered it falls
on deaf ears and on closed doors in this
Congress the word environment was never
mentioned in the so called contract with
America
it wasn't mentioned because when that
document was put together they consulted
pollsters extensively and the pollsters
told them no there is nothing that your
backers and your coalition want with
respect to the environment that has any
chance of support with the American
people and so
left it out of their contract with
America but as soon as they seized
control of the Congress they launched an
all-out attack on America's ability to
protect the environment for two reasons
first because many of their most
powerful backers want to dump a lot more
pollution into the environment and don't
want to comply with the laws which
protect the environment and second they
have talked themselves into an extremist
ideological position which has convinced
them that we don't need to protect the
environment because somehow it can
protect itself healing itself from any
insult producing incentives for the
marketplace to clean it up without any
particular attention to harm that is
being done on a daily basis the American
people don't believe those things the
American people support environmental
protection overwhelmingly even Newt
Gingrich's
own pollster mr. Frank Luntz reported
that 62% of the American public
Republicans as well as Democrats choose
protecting the environment over cutting
regulations now as I will say in a few
moments we can cut unnecessary
regulations and improve protection of
the environment but given the choice
almost two thirds
of the American people in both political
parties say if that's the choice we
choose protecting the environment I know
that yesterday with administrator
browner you discussed the times-mirror
poll it showed almost 70% of Americans
strongly believe that environmental
protection and economic progress can go
hand in hand that's three times as many
as those who believe we have to make
what is really a false choice between
the two and the American people are
right it's a fact that hasn't escaped
all in the Republican Party some like
congressman Sherwood bollard Wayne
Gilchrist and other Republican moderates
took this message to heart
I commend congressman bowler for the
stand that he took on the anti
environmental measures included in the
Budget Reconciliation bill and his
courageous vote and the president and I
publicly commended congressman Gilchrist
in his own district for the stands that
he has taken in favor of protecting the
environment and I was proud to stand
next to Senator Mark Hatfield and some
other members of the Northwest
congressional delegation including
senator patty Murray and Senator Max
Baucus this past Monday as we announced
an historic bipartisan agreement to
allow the Bonneville Power
Administration to maintain its ability
to protect salmon runs while
simultaneously remaining competitive in
the region all this proves that economic
concerns can be addressed without
compromising public health and the
environment
we said no to the people who would
override environmental protections and
in this case by doing so we said yes to
the environment and the economy of the
Pacific Northwest
so we are
anxious to work in a bipartisan way
where it is possible and as I mentioned
protection of the environment has
historically been a bipartisan activity
but unfortunately that is now the
exception many members of Congress
recognize that their constituents
support environmental protection but
instead of doing something about it the
Republican leadership is looking for
ways around it what better example than
the Republican Conference message
document passed around by the extremist
leadership that now controls that party
I hope that all of you get a copy of
this document it came out just within
the last two weeks when their pollsters
began flashing red lights and sounding
alarm bells and telling them that they
were about to fall off the edge of an
electoral cliff on environmental issues
it fought the memo though falls under
the category if I didn't see it with my
own eyes I would have never believed it
it literally acknowledges that the
environment is an important issue and
then makes not a single recommendation
for a substantive response to this issue
of such concern to the American people
instead it urges Republican members of
Congress quote in order to build their
credibility quote engage this agenda
before your opponents can label your
efforts craven election year gimmicks it
then proceeds to list a menu full of
craven election year gimmicks not about
sound policy they suggest plant a tree
clean a park start a task force release
a statement
and my personal favorite establish a
Teddy Roosevelt conservation award it's
true that Teddy Roosevelt cared deeply
about the environment
he once said the nation behaves well if
it treats the natural resources as
assets which it must turn over to the
next generation increased and not
impaired in value Teddy Roosevelt left
an important legacy for Republicans and
Democrats and yet on the anniversary of
his birthday yesterday actually October
27th he must have been turning over in
his grave as members of his political
party very different in tone and
character from what it was when he led
it we're reading this list of Craven
gimmicks to try to posture themselves as
not being against environmental
protection while at the same time
pursuing this extremist agenda the
Senate too followed the example of their
counterparts in the house and passed
another part of their extremist budget
which when all totaled will eliminate
our ability in Roosevelt's words to
behave well and to treat natural
resources as assets this document and
the approach it represents is breeding
ground for cynicism it describes in some
detail how elected officials can who'd
wink their constituents to pretend that
they are in sync with public concerns
for safe and clean water fresh air and
sustainable lands and once again this
document shows why this is without any
doubt what
so ever the most anti-environment
Congress in history because they can
plan a tree adopt-a-highway or even give
out a Teddy Roosevelt award but they
cannot escape the wisdom articulated in
the famous words of another Republican
president Abe Lincoln when he said you
can fool some of the people all of the
time and all of the people some of the
time but you cannot fool all of the
people all of the time they may think
they can but they cannot they will not
fool President Clinton they will not
fool environmental journalists and they
will not fool the American people they
will not fool their own moderates
including the few among them who have
demonstrated the courage to stand up to
this extremist agenda the fact remains
regardless of their attempts at deceit
the Republican leadership in the name of
a balanced budget supports sweeping cuts
in everything that affects the
environment and their cuts written by
special interests in the back rooms of
Congress without debate some
investigative journalists among your
ranks have fared it out the incredible
story of how the lobbyists for the
biggest polluters in America were
invited to walk right into the halls of
Congress given their own room just off
the floor of the Congress they literally
held the chairs before them so to speak
gave them the pen and invited them to
rewrite the environmental laws and these
lobbyists and lawyers are paid large
sums of money by companies that want to
reduce their costs associated with
cleaning up pollution why would they be
given
the power to change our laws governing
the very pollution that their employers
are dumping aren't the laws supposed to
be written by elected officials and
those directly accountable to them and
through them to the American people
isn't it a disgrace in this land of the
free and home of the brave to have
polluters given the authority to change
the laws that affect them have we become
so numb to the basic standards of
decency and ethics and public service
that prevailed in Teddy Roosevelt's time
in Abraham Lincoln's time in Samuel
Adams time that this is a one-day story
who were these lobbyists what are each
of the changes they made how much money
is involved how much pollution is
involved it is a disgrace it is the
auctioning off of self-government
it's the selling of democracy to the
highest bidder covered by public
relations and gimmicks that they hope
will be rolled out soon enough so that
you won't see them as gimmicks the Clean
Water Act was rewritten in this manner
the Superfund proposal now being debated
was rewritten in this manner and the
legal briefs by companies that dump the
pollution show up
in the actual legislative proposals
word-for-word whole sections completely
unchanged I think that these extremists
really have convinced themselves that
there is a way for them to pretend that
it's ethical I think they have convinced
themselves that those with more money
and power know more about the economy
and have superior knowledge about the
subject matter that's being dealt with
because after all in their view any
assertion of the public interest is
suspect probably designed in their view
just to add to the power and size of the
hated government and so since there is
no credible counter force within the
confines of this extremist philosophy
they're justified in turning to the
people who know the subject matter the
best the polluters they would eliminate
all state loan funds that help local
drinking water facilities treat
contaminants thousands of tons of
industrial toxics would be allowed to
pour into our rivers lakes and streams
we would not be able to enforce
environmental laws that keep raw sewage
off beaches and off and out of our
waterways our error would be dirtier to
special interests worked with Congress
to block health protections that would
control toxic air pollutants emitted by
oil refineries and hazardous waste
incinerators both of which emit
chemicals that can cause cancer
respiratory illness and reproductive
damage they would cut funds for
enforcement of environmental laws by 50
while simultaneously requiring the
Environmental Protection Agency to jump
through a lot of new hoops
held up by the same lawyers and
lobbyists who take them to court at the
drop of a dime under the new provisions
they would put into the law so while
they have 50% less resources to enforce
the law they have a doubled workload to
answer interrogatories and satisfy
special tests devised by the polluters
themselves the cleanup of toxic waste
dumps would be slowed and in many cases
stopped altogether they want to cut
cleanup funds by 1/3 even though one out
of every four Americans now lives within
four miles of a Superfund site they
would take away our community's right to
know now there's an interesting one why
do they want to take away the
communities right to know the ability of
environmental journalists to get
information about how much pollution is
being dumped from particular facilities
in the community where you live there's
a list as you know of toxic pollutants
that now have to be reported under the
right to know act well they want to kill
that because they have learned from
painful experience then when people know
about the pollution that's being dumped
into their air and water they become
active in demanding that it stop if they
can be kept ignorant deprived of the
information then that pesky activism may
come to a stop they know from experience
that communities of people who live
around polluters can be pushed around
and kept under their thumb if they are
deprived of any information about the
pollution that's affecting them the
Congress plans also to virtually
eliminate funds that now help businesses
develop cleaner cost-effective
technology to help clean up pollution
this is by the way a booming industry
creating high wage jobs and allowing our
businesses in America to dominate one of
the fastest growing sectors of the world
economy and of course if all this isn't
enough they've also attached 17 riders
to the EPA's appropriations bill these
riders give special deals to the special
interests at the expense of the American
people they would mean more air
pollution and more toxic waste in our
water they would mean less safety and a
dirtier environment because they too
were written by the lobbyists there too
the exact language in many of these
riders has been traced back to the
identical wording from law firms hired
by the polluters the vote on these
riders incidentally has been put off the
tide is beginning to turn a little bit
as these efforts are being unmasked
Republican leaders know that they don't
have the votes they need to keep these
special interest riders in the
appropriations bill they need more time
to pressure their own moderates to
protect these loopholes they know that
they are far outside the mainstream on
these issues and so they're putting off
the day of reckoning
I want to formally urge speaker Gingrich
and Majority Leader dal to go forward
with a vote on these issues first of all
in the House of Representatives
it's time for them to vote they owe it
to the American people I dare them to
vote on it I want to see the names next
to the green and red lights in the
chamber I don't think they can keep
these riders in there bill I only wish
that their unprecedented assault had
ended with EPA's budget however in a
measure that has already passed through
the Congress the extremists got their
way on sham mining reform mining reform
that does very little to correct the
problems of the 1872 mining act and
could actually make it worse recently
secretary Babbitt was forced to sign
over more than 1 billion dollars worth
of minerals for 275 dollars we might
have used that 1 billion to help avoid
Medicare withering on the vine to help
avoid some of the other extremist items
on their agenda but they wanted to give
it to a special interest
they've also adopted a plan to
drastically increase logging in the
Tongass and to do it without regard for
environmental laws and of course there
is the drilling of the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge a unique ecosystem that
is home to hundreds of plant and animal
species President Clinton has stated
many times that we should prohibit oil
drilling in this biologically rich
wilderness and work instead to protect
its coastal plain while ensuring that
Native Americans can use these lands for
traditional hunting and fishing
yesterday Senator Baucus amendment to
take Anwar out was defeated on a close
vote 51 to 48 the closeness is itself
another sign that many Republicans are
just beginning to realize that people
don't approve of what they're doing
incidentally the most
optimistic estimates of how much oil
would be found in Anwar is significantly
less than what they have just eliminated
in the form of energy conservation and
efficiency measures
well this agenda shows us that the
leadership has not gotten the message
and on this particular item President
Clinton's message is clear any
reconciliation bill that opens an waar
to drilling he will veto period doesn't
matter what else is in the bill if they
satisfied us on 100% of every single of
every other item in that bill and they
opened Anwar to drilling
he will veto it it's just that clear
I know you're visiting Walden Pond
tomorrow and when I think of the
devastating consequences to both public
health and the environment that this
extremist agenda will bring I'm reminded
of something that Thoreau once wrote
thank God they cannot cut down the
clouds which brings me to the global
issues like ozone depletion and climate
change some people just aren't getting
the point
two weeks ago a distinguished scientist
and personal friend who is in the
audience here this evening Mario Molina
won a Nobel Prize along with Sherwood
Rowland and a Dutch colleague Paul
Crutzen for their historic work on ozone
depletion
soon after the award an international
panel of scientists found on the issue
of climate change what many are calling
a smoking gun proof that human activity
has already been responsible for
increasing global temperatures there's
long been no doubt that it will increase
temperatures and little doubt that it
has probably already done so but the
remaining uncertainty that it has
already done so has been seized upon by
some skeptics as an argument that we
really don't know enough to act but now
they have said we do know enough to act
that didn't stop Tom DeLay the
Republican leader in the House of
Representatives from saying that the
phase-out of ozone depleting CFCs was
the result of quote a media scare
I guess he's talking about you
and they've not only cut the programs to
fight global climate change they've cut
the research too it's a two-step process
stop the remedy and claim that we don't
know enough to act and then say we don't
want to know anymore
keep us ignorant it echoes back to the
Community right-to-know debate it's the
scientific equivalent of book-burning
well we don't know can hurt us and
they're making a huge mistake because
protecting the world we live in should
not be a political issue we want a
balanced budget there's a right way in a
wrong way though and as the debate over
the balanced budget continues my message
is very simple we should keep our eyes
on the prize and not forget why we're
working to balance the budget in the
first place we want to do it in order to
improve the quality of life for all
Americans and to prepare for the future
if we destroy the environment in the
process or destroy our ability to
protect it in the future
then that's counterproductive that's why
President Clinton from the very first
day of his presidency has shown a deep
commitment to environmental protection
and the promotion of public health and
that's true of efforts to cut toxic
emissions and keep our water clean to
pursue sustainable development and
invest in environmental technologies to
lead the world in Cairo at the United
Nations Population Conference to
establish a new consensus on how to
stabilize world population it's true of
executive order after executive order
but at the same time the president
realizes that we not only need to
protect our resources we need to make
environmental protection work better and
cost less
we've improved as a protection of
everything from water and air to meet
standards and home ownership we've made
common-sense reforms to ensure that the
vast majority of homeowners
never again have to worry about wetlands
or endangered species laws improving the
protection while eliminating the
unnecessary hassle in March we released
a report entitled reinventing
environmental regulation with 25 new
initiatives designed to improve the
current system of Environmental
Protection and to chart the course for a
new generation of environmental policy
reducing paperwork for example and of
course there's project XL under which
companies can achieve that can achieve
better environmental results under their
own management system will be allowed to
do just that
give us a way to monitor the progress
and a commitment to make it and we'll
throw away the rule book also I want to
applaud EPA New England and Regional
Administrator John de villiers for the
work in pushing through common-sense
reform these are just a few examples of
how we can improve the protection of the
environment while at the same time
holding fast to our commitment to make
it better now in closing earlier I
mentioned Teddy Roosevelt he once said
that the first requisite of a good
citizen in this Republic of ours is that
he shall be able and willing to pull his
weight in other words as President
Clinton has said personal responsibility
and citizenship go hand in hand
that can't be just the province of
citizens it must also be the province of
governments we will respond to this
challenge you have our pledge that this
administration will stand and fight for
the legislation that has meant so much
for our country and at the same time
strive to make it work better and cost
less from you we just ask that you keep
doing what you have always done continue
to work hard to improving the quality
accuracy and visibility of environmental
reporting continue to let people know
what will come from this unprecedented
assault that the extremists are waging
on our and
Barma continued to report on those who
misrepresent their views to their
constituents together with the American
people we can make a difference
regardless of party or ideology not only
in creating a balanced budget that
reflects our common values but in
safeguarding public health and creating
a clean and sustainable environment when
Sam Adams tossed that box of tea into
the Boston Harbor he wasn't violating
the Clean Water Act back then there
wasn't one nor did we really need one
but today our challenges are different
our goal however remains the same making
sure that we all do our part in making
certain that America's best interests is
served thank you very much
thank you
yeah I'd be good thank you very much
we'll start over here on this side and
then I'll alternate sorry my name is
Frank McDonald I'm the environment
correspondent of the Irish Times in
Dublin in Ireland and you won't remember
this mr. vice president but we met at
Rio at the Earth Summit and I introduced
you to our den prime minister Albert
Reynolds yes whom you've met a lot quite
quite as much since then yes indeed what
I want to concentrate on tonight is the
global issue of climate change and what
the u.s. stance is on it and what I
wanted to ask you was in view of the
fact the inescapable fact that this
country contains only 4% of the world's
population and yet contributes about 25%
of co2 emissions what concrete steps is
the US administration taking in the
context of the global or the Framework
Convention for climate change and in
particular what chances do you see of a
stronger protocol that commits the US
and other industrialized countries into
real reductions being approved by this
US Congress in view of the shocking
catalog of Chicana e that you've been at
you've revealed tonight could you repeat
that last phrase
I like the the way you said that thank
you very much okay
thank you
the administration has put forward a
climate action plan that has been
attacked by this Congress and it is
apparent that if their cuts went into
effect the climate action plan would be
devastated when that plan was put
forward we said at the time that has
circumstances changed we would modify it
to set more ambitious goals we still
intend to do that this Congress
obviously is not going to pass it but
Congress is to come will and let me draw
an analogy between the world's response
to global climate change and the world's
response to the work of Mario Molina and
sherry Rowland and others on
stratospheric ozone depletion the
Montreal Protocol is often cited as a
landmark world agreement to phase out
the chemicals responsible for
stratospheric ozone depletion but it was
not an event it was a process and still
is a process and in the early years of
that process it was impossible to pass
legislation in the United States or in
any other country to phase out these
chemicals in very common use but as the
scientific consensus grew firmer and
firmer and as the scientific community
found ways to
communicate with the society at large
about the extremely dangerous
consequences of stratospheric ozone
depletion it became possible to take
more aggressive action that same process
is now underway with regard to global
climate change it will be harder because
we're chlorofluorocarbons and the other
chemicals that deplete stratospheric
ozone were important parts of the
economy they were not interwove on with
the sinews of industrial society as
carbon dioxide is nevertheless the
evidence is now so compelling and will
become even more compelling that soon we
will pass a threshold beyond which what
seems impossible now will seem
imperative I realize we're not there yet
but change often comes according to this
pattern not slowly and gradually but
threshold to threshold new reality to
new reality in 1988 the extremely hot
temperatures and the hypodermic needles
on the beaches and the dead seals in the
North Sea beaches and other phenomena
created a new plateau of awareness in
Mount Pinatubo and a variety of other
factors caused a few years of diminished
concern 1995 may well turn out to be the
hottest year in recorded history when
the calculations are finalized at the
end of the year the first nine and a
half months make it almost certain that
that will be the case
and in Germany the connection in the
public in the public mind between the
historic flooding of the Rhine and the
strange weather phenomena with global
climate change has already produced a
new political reality in Germany in
Australia we're seeing a similar
phenomenon and the day is not far off
when we shall see it in the United
States as well yes my name is bid any
secret of I see I am mister Villanova's
translator so make this quit this
question on his behalf
so mr. vice president what do you think
of the continuation of the French
nuclear tests in mrudula
I thought I gave you the hard news
already we have committed ourselves in
the clinton-gore administration and in
our country to a comprehensive test-ban
no more tests other many other countries
have done the same thing I understand
the outrage that has been expressed over
the continuation of French testing but
to those who feel so angry about it I
would point to the statements about an
end soon after the current series and in
the long view if next year or the year
after we can establish a worldwide
comprehensive test-ban then this latest
series will be seen as part of the last
test before that occurred and I I
we'll try to avoid an international
incident with that formulation one of
the things we wanted to do is make sure
the MIT community was represented in the
questioning and knowing that they're not
as experienced as journalists in
muscling to the front I'm going to take
the Chairman's prerogative and call Mary
right behind you sir to the microphone
to let her ask her question thank you my
name is Mary Beth Wong I'm a graduate
student here at MIT and mr. vice
president
given that the use of technology is
tightly linked to both environmental
protection and degradation what are your
views on the recent closing of the
office of Technology Assessment and what
is the administration doing to ensure an
alternate nonpartisan source of
Technology Policy analysis for Congress
well I referred in earlier in to
different context to the seeming
imperative of the Republican majority in
Congress eliminating the Community
right-to-know for example eliminating
research on issue much research on
issues like climate change this is
another example the office of Technology
Assessment was set up Ted Kennedy was
one of the original authors of it
it was always bipartisan and the board
is evenly divided between Democrats and
Republicans and visitors from foreign
countries on every continent regularly
come to our Congress to see this model
of excellence in assessing new
technologies it's known around the world
as the best of its kind why do they want
to just eliminate it it's it's peculiar
the only way I can explain it is that
they fear the knowledge which comes from
it a a quasi survival of the fittest
philosophy is threatened by intelligence
and new information and so they just
wanted to eliminate it now you say will
we propose something for them to replace
it well we have the Office of Science
and Technology Policy in the White House
a Blee led by Jack Gibbons who was the
director of OTA in the Congress before
that and he's doing an outstanding job I
we're certainly in favor of keeping OTA
but if the majority there is bound to
eliminate it then there's not much we
can we can do to save them from
themselves mr. vice president
my name is David Swofford I'm an
associate member of this society and a
freelance business writer in Miami and
my question is this today this afternoon
we heard from three CEOs of very
important American companies here and
according to them American business
realizes the good that comes from
environmental protection as and is in
effect positioning itself to continue
working on the problems for the good of
the country
if that is so then what it seemed that
the Republican Congress is out of touch
with their traditional constituents or
in your opinion are these CEOs in effect
misleading us us journalists here I
would doubt that the latter is is true I
don't know the individuals you're
referring to but I do know that there
are lots and lots of CEOs who understand
this very clearly and who understand as
well that
their profits to be made in but by doing
the right thing
and many of them have been helpful to us
in trying to stop this extremist agenda
but a great many others probably not the
ones who came to speak with you but a
great many others who would like to be
moderate and understand why they should
be reasonable felt as if they were put
in a peculiar position by the Republican
takeover of Congress because many in
their industries that wanted to cut
corners were being given the green light
to do so and if they were not part of
that general movement in their industry
then they felt like there were at some
risk I mean I I have this mental image
of 60 days into the Newt Gingrich
Congress had this mental image of
lobbyists gathered at a local watering
hole after work in near the Capitol and
a lobbyist for a company that's not at
the trough getting it while the getting
is good is sort of ridiculed and derided
you know what's wrong with you you know
this is the historic chance to to
exploit and ravage pillage and at such a
time it takes a rare CEO indeed to stand
up and say no this is the time to stand
on principle some of them have more of
them were about to I mean I hear from
more of them now who want to to take a
different approach one quick example of
this at the end of 1994 in August and
September we had completed
a reform of the Superfund law that every
environmental group supported and almost
every industry group supported senator
Dole filibustered it and prevented it
from passing after the election in
January we went back to some of the very
same companies that had signed on to the
bill in 94 and told them we're ready to
go
will you still support us and they said
no I'm sorry because we would incur the
wrath of the Republican leadership if we
supported an administration initiative
like this now that they're putting out
this list of gimmicks and backpedaling
and trying to bob and weave to escape
the political fallout from their
extremism some of these companies are
coming back and saying ok now we're
ready to play ball and try to get a good
bill I'm president of the Senate yes I I
closed my letters and then I said
so now with both dies mr. vice president
my name is mr. my name is Mohammad Shah
Jahan I'm a freelance journalist and
chairman of Bangladeshi environment
Council as well as Secretary General
Abdul Rauf Human Rights ban adesh hmm
well I'd like to create your attention
as well as whole audience
well you we know that environment is
good advantages God gifted things but we
people with the human beings make
pollution out of it so you know you open
hurt one of your estate Michigan and our
Bangladeshis almost every years flood
occurs you know but you know as US
people as well as you government having
the highest regards to at the United
Declaration of Human Rights and even
charter and you know that everyone has
the right to equal share of the natural
things but we the Bangladeshi people
about four or five core people and the
northern part of our country during the
dry season we are not given water and
our northern part getting desired and
during the rainy season we are giving
over water so plaid occurs every time
and four or five caught people getting
homeless and for one month's two months
they are just living on the street
having no food and no shelter and just
this is created by our neighboring
country you know India so I would like
to know what this community as well as
your government and you can play the
role out of it
so that this problem can be solved
because we have the equal right to the
natural things in Rio at the Earth
Summit nations around the world
committed themselves in principle to the
idea of sustainable development that is
a commitment to provide more
opportunities for people around the
world
in ways that don't diminish the quality
of future opportunities
putting that principle into practice
requires cooperation between the
developed countries and the developing
countries north and south east and west
we are attempting to do our part but the
world as a whole has not yet grasped the
urgency of moving forward aggressively
to deal with this challenge in Cairo we
made progress toward dealing with one
aspect of the challenge that is
stabilizing world population it'll take
a lot of time we need to develop a new
generation of technologies that will
allow increased productivity without the
harsh effect on the environment most
importantly we need to change our way of
thinking about this challenge
you know the interconnection between
your country and the rest of the world
is far from unique you talked about
excuse me
Baraka berries acai berries I talked
about the Farakka yeah I talked about
the far acai berries with the India for
acai berries you heard about it the
berries Baraka Oh
oh I'm sorry you know I'm sorry all
right fine well I I'm not going to get
into an issue between you and and India
but I think that many of the large dams
proposed around the world of course were
planned in an era before environmental
analysis had matured the Three Gorges
Dam for example we just withdrew our
support for that in China even though
it's a very high priority for for China
your floodplain of course is a place
where millions have recurrent nightmares
but but let me draw the connection to
local communities that are within the
coverage areas of many of the American
journalists who are here I wonder how
many of the American journalists here
have covered in the last decade a
hundred year flood and then the
following year covered another hundred
year flood has anybody had that
experience quite a few hands are going
up one of the latest findings that will
be reported in the IPCC report in
February shows that one consequence of
global climate change is increased
droughts and increased flooding because
the percentage of total precipitation
which comes in extreme events measured
as what mario over one inch per 24 hour
period something like that the
percentage of precipitation that comes
in extreme events has been going up
steadily as the models predict so you
get more droughts and more flooding
of course the de neuting of the
foothills of the himalayas and the
watershed of the Great Rivers which
drain through Bangladesh has also
brought silt down the mountain sides and
raised the the bed of your river so that
the carrying capacity has greatly
diminished so the tendency to come over
the banks and flood the areas where
people live is much greater
when you come when you look at the
combined impact of deforestation soil
erosion climate change and population
growth the combined effect is much worse
than the effects of either of these of
any of these separately and then when
you talk about solving the problem it's
a long-term project and it has to be a
worldwide effort I wrote a whole book
about exactly what I think ought to be
done and I'm not going to try to to to
go into all of the details here but I
really believe that it's something that
must dominate the the decades to come in
the world debate about this let me just
take one more just one more thank you my
name is Julie Edelson I work for the
trade journal inside EPA and also
freelance for the New York Times I
wanted to ask you sort of a two-fold
question first about the super car
initiative which has been criticized for
not really moving fast enough or going
anywhere this idea of developing this
really fuel-efficient car and also if
you believe in the in light of these
these aggressive efforts by Republicans
if there's any chance to the cafe
standards are going to increase
especially for trucks which are being
purchased by a larger amount of the
population and if not what the
implications of that are going to be
well on the second question you know the
Congress just voted to prevent any cafe
increase but on the first question the
partnership for a general new generation
of vehicles is designed not to just get
a tenth of a gallon increase or two
tenths of a gallon but a three times
increase in fuel efficiency a car in
other words at today's prices and
today's standards of performance and
comfort and marketability and price that
gets three times the mileage of current
cars we consciously set a goal to be
reached in 10 years time we've got eight
years to go that
beyond what can be reached with current
technology in order to push out of the
current technologies and identify new
ones you say that we're behind schedule
I don't know where that comes from we're
actually I would argue that we're ahead
of schedule we have a different group of
technologists and scientists and
engineers coming into the white house
every month the dealing of my wife and I
just had a reception in our home for the
battery scientists and capacitor
scientists and they're making great
progress but but but we're really very
excited about this about this initiative
and I think it's going to work let me
close ladies and gentlemen by thanking
you very much for your hospitality and
the invitation to speak here thank you
very much
you